je vous montre un truc qui est super
impressionnant et vraiment intéressant
c'est de la recharge ici à l'hydrogène
alors la marque s'appelle nameix là vous
avez vos petites recharges à hydrogène
alors il y a déjà un réservoir mais en
plus de ça vous avez vos petites charges
comme ça vous avez plus qu'à l'apprendre
et vous allez directement derrière venir
la poser le truc qui est vachement cool
c'est qu'en fait lorsque vous manquez
d'hydrogène et vous avez pas forcément
et bien de quoi venir en récupérer vous
le prenez vous le posez vous en prenez
une autre vous la mettez dedans vous
avez déjà un premier plan qui me permet
de faire 500 km et en plus ici avec vos
différentes recharges à l'hydrogène vous
montez jusqu'à plus de 800 km et ça
c'est vachement bien la marque s'appelle
MX c'est une collaboration
franco-marocaine